[Musique]
m
je suis double jeu avec laurent baffie
françois rollin philippe corti patrick
adler maître capello nagui karen cheryl
et guy lux voici double jeu spécial jeux
télé
[Musique]
demain soir bienvenue au premier bergar
pour jouer avec nous tout bleu jeu trois
candidats vont s'affronter ce soir pour
emporter le sceptre du vainqueur
notre premier candidat s'appelle qui il
a 70 ans est lui à neuilly et son hobby
c'est la pêche à la truite dans le jura
il porte ce soir les couleurs de france
3 guy va-t-il rafler la cagnotte
affaire à suivre
[Applaudissements]
notre deuxième candidat est une
candidate elle s'appelle karen elle a 35
ans elle vit à paris et son hobby c'est
faire du bateau avec son papa elle
portait les couleurs de france 3
karan va-t-elle décrocher le jackpot on
va voir
[Applaudissements]
notre troisième candidat s'appelle nagui
il a 31 ans et lui à paris décidément
c'est un derby parisien ce soir son
hobby c'est la moto le tennis est
préparé des bouffes pour ses copains il
porte en lui les couleurs de france 2
nagui sera-t-il obligé d'utiliser son
joker on va le savoir tout de suite
plus con c'est dur
m
[Musique]
pour plus tard ouais est fourbu l'heure
c'est bien d'avoir pu me confond alors
mesdames messieurs bonsoir avant de
commencer ce mini débat en forme
d'interview parallèle je voudrais vous
dire que suite aux nombreux dérapages
qui ont émaillé les émissions de double
jeu nous avons demandé ce soir à maître
capello d'être parmi nous
rétro capello bonsoir bonsoir chers
thierry bonsoir vaste public alors
maître capello vous publier le guide du
français correct c'est ça aux éditions
de l'archipel parfaitement pour éviter
que les gens ne fassent des fautes qu'il
ne commettrait pas si on leur a pris si
on leur avait appris la langue au moment
juste un moment je n'ai maître capello
par exemple vous débusquer les
néologismes et barbarisme et plein de
néologismes simplement les faux emplois
oui exemple vous avez une carte que la
nappe les mappemondes vont très bien
elle est formée de deux cercles planète
en jean et alors les gens croient bon de
baptiser mappemonde un globe ça n'a
aucun rapport
donc appeler les choses par leur nom et
ce n'est pas tout vous dit ce garçon
dégagement raté il est déjà grande et
comprenait et j'en passe tu préfères pas
qu'on dérape
vers ap maître capello vous traquez
aussi les contre sens les faux sont ces
non sens et les non censurée de vers
dont je viens de parler de la mappemonde
je parle là de bien d'autres encore une
des quatre et dix jours chez ma mère oui
pourquoi baptisé décade une période de
10 ans voilà ça ne va pas je sais pas si
des leviers et musclé c'est à mon sens
parce que bercy va être compensées tu as
vu laurent j'ai une question à poser à
capello qu'est ce que voulait faire
quand vous serez devant vous et des
projets
alors maître capello inutile de vous
dire si vous vous apercevez que vous
voulez et que ça fait chier tout le
monde
c'est nécessaire je veux et à rentrer
chez toi petit bonhomme
alors nous allons commencer le mini
débat première question donc je vais
commencer par toi parce que comme tu le
sais ça tourne dans le sens des
aiguilles d'une montre quelle est la
différence puisque tout un débat sur les
jeux télé quelle est la différence entre
un jeu télé intelligente et un jeu télé
qu'on t'avait dit des questions soient
pas intégrés c'est bien il justifie son
salaire est impeccable mais c'est un
gros ça je paye cher très cher ah ouais
pourra peut-être changé elle va plus
pour longtemps hélas pas trop longtemps
c'est ce qu'on dit vrai je ferme ma
gueule parce que j'ai toujours présente
et que des jeux complets
nagui est la différence entre un jeu
télé intelligente
ce dépendent non ça dépend peut-être des
fois des gens qui le font et non dans
les deux sens soient les candidats il ya
des candidats qui sont qu on peut les
mettre dans n'importe quel jeu ils sont
toujours qu'on et puis il ya des
présentateurs qui sont cons on peut les
mettre dans n'importe quel jeu même pas
en jeu ils sont encore qu'on dans la rue
ce questionnaire foot attend à péter
hors-concours quelque chose et ajoutait
et non s'il en a pas marre d'être
planqué derrière sa caméra même cherche
là je sais pas moi j'aime direction de
ma vie quand le mariage
on va voir j'aime bien la définition de
baby quand il parle des jeux notamment
du jeu du millionnaire ou widi le jeu
des millionnaires s'est fait par ces
faits pour des cons qui ont du poc et
pour des cons combat de poids qui
regardent des comptes rendus populaires
alors vous avez demandé la parole oui
ben écoutez tiré d'abord je voudrais me
féliciter d'avoir enfin quitter l'espèce
de guérites à paillettes ridicule dans
laquelle vous m'avez bien installé
depuis le début de l'année je n'ai rien
contre les paillettes naturellement mais
enfin j'avais besoin d'un bureau
correcte où je puisse travailler
sérieusement et m'acquitter de la
mission que vous m'avez confiée à savoir
une sorte de surveillance morale de
cette émission qui il faut bien le dire
à un petit peu tendance à partir dans
tous les sens thierry d'abord avec tous
ses flonflons et toutes ces paillettes
justement toutes ces trompettes toutes
ses dorures tous et tralala qui sont un
peu déplacé je dirais même qui frise
l'indécence dans un pays qui je vous le
rappelle est tout de même assez
gravement touché par la crise et puis
surtout thierry il ya toutes ces
grossièretés qui fusent dans tous les
sens et là je crois que vous n'avez pas
fait le bon choix avec baffier qui
manifestement ne
parvient pas à s'exprimer poliment et
puis vous tirez vous n'êtes pas tout
blanc non plus question grossièretés
alors ça rime à quoi de dire tant de
gros mots n'est ce pas ça rime à quoi ça
vous avant ce à quoi vous trouvez
peut-être que c'est drôle mais ça ne
fait rire que vous je vous le garantis
alors c'est quoi c'est pour faire de
l'audimat 1 c'est ça alors à propos de
l'audimat dirige vous avez été observée
la semaine dernière qu'il est malsain
d'essayer de faire de l'audimat avec des
filles et avec du sexe vous avez un
petit peu tenu compte c'est un petit peu
mieux ce soir c'est un tout petit peu
mieux mais enfin tout de même les jeux
télé un tir et vous ne croyez pas que
les français s'intéressent à autre chose
que les jeux télé vous êtes sur le
service public non d'une pipe est ce
qu'il n'ya pas mieux à faire que de
s'occuper de jeter les débiles animé par
des animateurs des bills 1 alors essayez
quand même d'en tirer
je vous aurais prévenu
[Musique]
nos services ont alors fait toujours
dans l'actualité tu ne quitte pas
l'actualité puisque à une émission sur
france 3 qui s'appelle comment les
intervilles du rire c'est ça oui oui oui
exactement moi je comptablement aussi en
amérique alors c'est quoi on c'est toute
une histoire que je vais essayer de de
condenser c'est une émission je fais en
réaction six films x je ne sois pas du
tout réactionnaire en réaction à un
concept qui a été soi disant trouvé par
mon ami si on peut dire comme ça
j'arrive à qui un jour s'est dit tiens
on pourrait faire un intervilles sur le
rire quand j'ai vu ça j'ai dit c'est
quand même curieux que moi qui ait
blanchi sous le harnais depuis
maintenant une bonne trentaine d'années
avec les intervilles les internets des
interclasses les inters continent et
j'en passe et des meilleurs les
intérieurs du sénat
qui a le mieux marché c'est les
interminables files interminables
alors j'ai eu cette réaction jeudi c'est
quand même un peu vache un piqué ça
quand même alors j'ai proposé à notre
bonne chaîne iii où je travaille pas mal
où il ya beaucoup de copains et copines
de bien vouloir faire les intervilles du
rire alors actuellement il ya vrai il ya
une vraie bagarre entre la chaîne dit
tf1 et la chaîne dite fr3 en parlant ce
producteur qui lui fait la même émission
donc sur tf1 quelques quelques jours
plus tard tu dis que toi tu avait
inventé l'idée de jouer avec les dates
de naissance aussi et quitte à piquer
aussi pour sacrée soirée c'est vrai ça
c'est tellement vrai que ça m'est arrivé
d'une manière tout à fait impromptue
inattendu un jour à un feu rouge ça fait
des années que que je suis trouvé les je
ne sais plus cause qu'est ce qu'on doit
dire si c'est intelligent ou con de
faire jouer les gens en ont les
concernant tous alors j'ai je cherchais
sur les plaques minéralogiques
sur les cartes d'action sociale sur les
cartes d'identité
et puis ça ne concernait pas tout le
monde est bien beau jour un feu rouge je
vois sur une espèce de truc lit mineur
qui défilent dans paris de votre
naissance à votre mort vous serez
assurés par dortmund je ne sais pas et
là c'était avec lic me suis dit mais
effectivement la seule chose dont on est
propriétaire de sa naissance à sa mort
c'est sa date de naissance voilà le truc
pour faire jouer tout le monde alors je
les fais une deux fois notamment des
missions qui s'appelait c'est
aujourd'hui demain ou toujours sur cette
bonne chaîne iii alors quand j'ai vu ça
tous les ans dans intervilles je disais
j'ai prêté 10 mois de suite
les dates de naissance manet me foucault
mais vous permettez que je reprenne mon
bien pendue bellemare la tête et les
jambes c'est une idée à toi aussi c
un petit peu une idée à moi là je suis
un peu de plus en plus nuancée autant
l'autre c'est vraiment un hold up comme
caractérisé autant la tête et les gens
c'est différent un jour je vais trouver
alors j'étais un
tout nouveau dans le métier et j'avais
trouvé qu'un truc était marrant c'est de
faire un muscle esprits hautmont au tour
de france on prenait le mec le gros mois
le dernier parce que les premiers ils
sont jamais d'accord pour pour se mettre
son entraîneur on prenait le dernier de
l'étape il courait pendant qu'un post
est donc c'est toi aussi alors j'ai
appelé ça le muscle esprits mais je dois
reconnaître comme jacques antoine y
amener sa patte et puis antenne 2 août
avait piqué jeux sans frontières sinon
assez fou le nombre d'idées quant à les
lire ici le savent parce que moi à
procès ont la peau mais à tulle a pour
but la mère d'un dimanche et toit
léger dimanche non mais pourtant je suis
désolé de te dire effectivement que dans
les musulmans je m'appliquais un truc
qui est extraordinaire et je devrais
toucher des droits le passé le pas
chez les droits sur fiat lux depuis la
création des messes du dimanche moi je
sais pas le podium je rêve creek je suis
prête à trouver quand même une grande
idée aussi c'est le tiercé parce que
quand quand on allait donner à gérer un
magasin à boulogne quand on peut le dire
quand même ans était pas un magasin
c'était une quincaillerie quincaillerie
et tu avais l'arrivée d'une étape à
boulogne mais j'ai mis une urne devant
la porte et tu avais dit aux gens
d'aller ceux qui trouvent les trois
gagnants de l'étape dans l'ordre ils ont
droit je sais plus et 10000 france
étaient conduits miso ici d'achat non
c'était à l'époque la monnaie était pas
la même que maintenant je m'emmerde et
lens moyens et tout d'un coup j'ai faut
que je trouve des idées alors j'ai foutu
une grande boîte à lettres si vous
amenez eux avant l'arrivée de l'étape
l'étroit dans l'ordre vous touche vous
prévenir dans le magasin vingt-cinq
mille balles si vous voulez dans le
désordre voyez que ça s'emballe alors ce
qui est terrible c'est que j'avais
quatre employés le premier jour il ya 25
à 2 2e 250 troisième jour tout le
quartier venaient de 1540 alors mon beau
frère qui est des propriétaires du
magasin quand il a vu que on ne faisait
plus que cela trier les cartes et on
s'occupait plus du tout de la clientèle
on sait plus une thune d'appel ni arrête
tes conneries c'est comme ça que mon
tiercé s'est arrêté mais que celui de
monsieur k russe qui passait devant
le magasin qui était le grand patron des
britanniques a rugi de la ville à 10
élèves en magasin à boulotter eu plein
d'idées mais enfin la plus grande comme
intervilles ça fait quoi d'être l'auteur
d'une institution nationale
pourquoi tu une institution à travers
villes en france mais le général de
gaulle en a parlé en conseil des
ministres en en faisant l'éloge d'un jeu
que même la mongolie nous envie
tu sais qu'elle essayait de la bande à
mavuba oui mon casque part on sait que
konrad adenauer le chancelier allemand
de l'époque avait demandé que ce soit
adaptée au niveau international c'est
devenu je sens fonctionne pas mais tu
dis c'est pas une incitation d'espèces à
thierry ça s'est passé en irak à
compiègne où là la petite histoire
rejoint la grande et ou à 2 noeuds
rencontrer souvent de gaulle et à un
moment un père de goldie de noël dit ma
chancelier je vais je vais vous quittez
quel tube the instant parce que je vais
arriver à une émission qui me plaît bien
et c'est d'autant plus avantageux pour
moi c'est que ce soit y ait deux mers
qui s'opposent qui sont des mères
gaulliste elle revient sensibles dit
d'ailleurs je vais vous dire cette
émission s'appelle intervilles et nous
devrions faire un intervilles entre la
france et l'allemagne c'est comme ça qui
élit jeu sans fonds c'est incroyable 1
ce qui est incroyable c'est que quand on
s'est réuni le lendemain chez le
ministre de l'information de l'époque
monsieur guy lux il a été installé tout
à fait à l'autre bout comme par hasard
tous les directeurs et sous-directeurs
les lieutenants des directeurs tout le
monde était là pour voir le ministre
parce que quand de gaulle disait c'est
comme local louis xiv en chaîne en
chaîne s'est fait chier tout le monde
d'accord je le suis je
pour laurent baffie qui joue le set dans
la troisième
voilà merci mais c'est un bon club
seville n'arrête
non ferme c'est pourquoi pourquoi n'y a
plus d' intervilles pas ce qui a pu si
tron oui oui
c'est tout à fait vrai on va lui
demander de te poser une question à
l'est on écoute bien à ça me fait
plaisir les ont ils si léon zitrone 16
114 2013 pour vous en direct le shérif
est ce que vous me recevez je ne
l'entends pas ah on me fait signe que
nous sommes de l'antenne ma question guy
vos contractuelles avec les chaînes
françaises belges et surtout suisse
court jusqu à 2037 vers quelle activité
allez vous vous consacrez en exclusivité
je vous donne le choix camelot éleveur
de vaches est par ailleurs sur lévriers
ou directeurs de casting à silicon
valley choisissez
alors
bien aussi le schmilblick immortalisé
par coluche le palmarès des chansons la
une et à vous la classe succès fou et la
roue tourne on se souvient de la roue
tourne la première émission on va la
regarder proton petit téléviseur der
garde
[Musique]
madame minvielle je reviens de marseille
il ya quelques jours et la branche de
vous dire que vous êtes devenu
maintenant la coqueluche de tout le
monde si l'on peut dire tout le monde
dit j'espère que notre petite maman
marseillaise va gagner et nous le
souhaitons tous vraiment parce que nous
savons que vous jouez pour vos trois
enfants surtout pour cette chance unique
qui s'offre à vous de gagner une petite
fortune jouer pour gagner une gamme cela
qui compte nous le souhaitons vivement
près vivement bonne chance contacter
madame muriel le cuissard ya général au
tourisme vous souhaite bonne route
quand on voit les images me rajeunit un
ouais tu avais pas le même nez comment
ça se fait
à sage et que j'étais avoir des trucs
que jean marc machin c'était avant quand
j'étais petit c'est toi par contre du
genre jeunesse à se faire ça se fera moi
je serais plus longtemps que c'était
inventons dérapage en alfa romeo c'est
ça oui 1 et a eu un accident et en a
profité pour non je n'ai pas profité du
tout non j'ai il me remet le nez comme
il était avant alors maintenant tu es
devenu un symbole national
il ya un temps quand même août est
drôlement non c'était drôlement critique
et moi je me souviens quand même j'ai
pris part j'ai pris beaucoup plus de
couches dans les données ont tapé le
fossoyeur de la culture nationale à
vénissieux posthume un instant souvient
de sa base c'est à dire que ce qui ce
qu'ils m'ont appelé le fossoyeur c'était
des journalistes de l'époque eux ils ont
tous disparus sont tous vous soyez si
j'ose dire et moi je suis toujours à
profit fond il faut s'en foutent
carrément la critique de touche elle m'a
beaucoup touché ouais on se serait
d'ailleurs mentir qu'elle me touche
parce qu'on est maintenant que je suis
plus vraiment à l'antenne son jeu
maintenant j'aime d'accord pour qu'elle
vous touche pas
c'était oui c'est du lourd c'est une
question d'habitude attiré une belle
fille la critique la plaisanterie qu'il
accepte
j'accepte l'ap les autres il faudrait
être fou pour faire des intervilles
toutes les émissions que j'ai fait est
pas acceptable entre et la moquerie la
moquerie le oui puisque j'ai tendance à
me moquer aussi tpr l axe que j'ai une
surprise je sais bien que tu vas me
faire non c'est gentil mais vas-y cabine
maryse n'est pas là heureusement j pour
vous simone
sifflé
[Applaudissements]
on a su me touche beaucoup
bravo
pour rocard
ça
à remarquer que c'est tout à fait calme
quand même il fait des cadeaux et les
rangs mène on va appeler lire notre
champion
il a tiré scheer public je suis de
retour à part séjour dans un pays gorgé
de soleil il est pur et simone avec non
effectivement mais thierry ardisson le
sait comme le disait le christ roi il
faut rendre à césar ce qui est à césar
alors mon cher guy bien je te rend une
fois pour toutes cette heure
si serré victoire
bah oui franck simone à la femme la plus
extraordinaire
intouchable incontournable il vaut mieux
et sur la tienne
c'est facile vous non ça allait quand
même pas d'une corpulence tels que
cantat motocyclistes fait le tour il
établit de s'arrêter pour faire le plein
non je veux dire que c'est une femme
fantastique et alors par contre la
moquerie j'adore j'aime bien mais celle
que j'ai lus par karl zéro pendant des
débuts str dire que toi et moi longtemps
que toi quand même et et wallace à notre
porte toi
c'est wasquehal 0 c'est moi est ce que
tu veux lui pardonner
m
c'était con de la traiter de [__]
voilà c'est toi qu'on y réfléchisse tu
cèdes et d'ailleurs j'ai un document
tu sais ce que c'est le voix de simone
que les années passées non non je n'ai
tu sais qu'en ce moment les animateurs
et les journalistes ont beaucoup de
problèmes et la g1 j'ai un document bien
embêtant pour tous et en 1960 tu te
souviens c'est pas si moi tu as dit à la
banque du sperme du boulevard le ferai
absous venir ça très bien sûrement fait
un don à don généreux d'ailleurs mon
chéri et pas à citer bien ce qui devait
arriver est arrivé nous voilà je
t'embrasse
dois je lui ai pardonné au travers de
moi pour ce parti simone athée dit ren
d'accord avec mon fils
[Applaudissements]
comme à
l'habitude simonet
vérité
encore sa cuisse ne te remettre journée
le tout remis des razzias de coke
j'adore turenne extrêmement drôle je
pense que c'est pour toi tu m'as lire le
scandale pédophile contaminé ça
t'intéresse prague
[Applaudissements]
dis-moi la fois un toc c'est pas toi qui
l'a inventé ça pas du tout sauf que
jacques antoine a fait l'émission je
mets juste de te le dire vrai fermée
pendant dix ans il s'appelait vous faut
ouais ouais j'ai un peu le même genre
bon alors tu es prêt sera une petite
info intox ou jouer tous les trois alors
c'est une question de denis km 75 paris
s de l'info ou de l'intox un tournoi de
foot pour les non voyants
karen
c'est possible hélas
pourquoi hélas franchement allez je vais
dire non je veux dire intox intox
nagui je vois pas
intox ouais guy je ferais presque n'ont
pas la même réponse que lui parce qu'il
était plein de drôlerie comment elle a
fait une fois je peux pas ne pas faire
le double on serait tenté de faire la
même réponse que karen un sa dot c'est
possible mais c'est dommage et c'est
triste si c'est vrai alors je suis tenté
de dire info - eh ben c'est toi qui a
gagné en un produit bien
doyon ont décidé de former une équipe de
foot il ya déjà des matchs en italie en
espagne
donc il ya sept joueurs il ya deux mi
temps d'une demi heure et quatre chiens
1 et 4 chez iliad et il ya des bébés bip
bip très très très puissant de chiens et
trois singes de bip bip très très
puissant dans les dents les dans les
bois dans les cages et ça marche et des
tournois internationaux de football pour
pour non voyants et d'ailleurs c'est
retransmis sur la sellette en soirée
absolument alors d'amicales mais
gagne 500 points alors pendant non c'est
pas de ma poche la finance in
corti et maître capello le score
il sait tout faire et tu regardes arrête
le score est tout de même faire un truc
rapidement sans les mecs avec la bouche
je vais faire ça m je le ferais non
point avec un piano à queue mais avec un
harmonica miniature
que je retire de sa gaine et vous aurez
jusqu'au petit après trois centimètres
et demi pas davantage à 9 ans et la
croatie
sont les mains ajouterais-je un autre
hama n'y a pas de mairie s'arrête au
profit de la route tour là je
guy lux mène 1 0 devant les deux autres
policiers
on arrive à faire des trucs avec et
d'anti enfer
mais finalement guy la télé ça ressemble
un petit peu finalement au jeu parce que
tu n'y a pas de justice il ya aucune
sécurité de l'emploi les patrons ça
change aussi souvent que les numéros est
ce que finalement
est ce que finalement il n'y a pas
quelque chose de commun entre le jeu et
la télévision ont complètement un camp
pennac laporte maire doit
attendre encore un peu
le jeu tu peux tu entends faire quand
même mais au jeu à la télé si tu loupes
ton coup de trois fois de suite tu te
dis moi c'est vrai qu'à l'âge de 15 ans
tu as gagné un gros paquet en mettant du
pognon sur un cheval qui s'appelait
mille usa dans le grand prix de paris
mais l'uso un médecin etc en plus du
pognon de tepic à ton père c'est vrai ça
totalement exact j'avais tuyaux dans un
petit bal que je fréquente et un petit
bal mal femme s'appelait la java 1 ou le
patron est venu un soir lady tous les
gosses là tous les jeunes à la neige ou
des natures machin chouette qui arrive
de normandie s'appelle mail usa mettez
votre pognon dessus et il n'a jamais
rien gagné et gagne demain sous-entendu
à l'été puis cause avait effectivement
j'ai bon
l'asie pitié non mais la lourde tomber
habile et ils sont repris craché
j'ai fixé deux tunnels mon père il est à
gagner ses missions mais les un cadre à
5 contre 1
il ya eu des choses qui est la dernière
des choses que j'aurais dû faire le vice
maire met dans la peau de la wii u des
choses plus tristes avec le jeu parce
que qui est une histoire terrible c'est
quelques jours avant noël où tu avais
joué tout le pognon mais allez on va
dire par des parts des arméniens hoarau
caire 1 je suis entré j'ai plus un sou
ni pour payer à manger dit que je
reviendrai je me serais me serais
suicidé sinon c'est une honte de
l'avouer mais depuis j'ai tellement
entendu ce type là ma femme et à mes
horaires eelv avec ta mère afin
pèlerinage à lisieux pour prier sainte
thérèse pour qu'ils s'intéressent fasse
perdre au jeu toute ma vie et que tu es
en fait que tu joues plus quoi mais bon
je continue à jouer mais je perds tout
le temps ouais donc ça a marché bah j'ai
l'impression que c'est le seul voeu qui
a été exaucé dans la famille est ce que
tu crois qu'on est joueur que tu n es
joueurs on est joueur comme on est
intelligent comme on est comblement des
mais je suis joueur et je dois dire que
comme j'ai beaucoup de soucis on vit pas
ça pour inciter les gens à les jouer si
j'entre sur un champ de courses dans un
casino s'est pas pourquoi je laisse mes
ennuis à la porte bien évidemment comme
je perds soit au duo jeu soit au casino
souhaite aux courses quand je les
retrouve mes ennemis ils ont doublé de
volume 1 mais j'ai vécu deux ou trois
heures complètement dans un autre monde
tu m'avais dit que j'avais perdu 500
millions de francs dans toute une vie
oui mais dis moi guy bon tu t'es fait
interdire un casino un moment oui y'a
plus qu'à la roulette que tu joues la le
baccara de chemin de fer à interdire à
celui qui est à 300 m 2 chinois indiens
qui est là en tant que je serai claude
ouais ouais et le loto tu joues
je suis pas tenté par la banque je suis
passé 30 ans petit téléviseur regarde
vous montrer un truc sur le tout ponctué
téléviseur terre ait hocine a dit
démarré en 1976 dans la confidentialité
le loto est devenu un fait de société
incontournable 12 à 13 millions de
bulletins sont validées chaque semaine
représente un musée de madère de plus de
200 millions de francs dévoilée par un
écho du parisien une étude
confidentielle sur les gagnants du loto
réalisé par la française des jeux révèle
un fait troublant et 68 milliardaire en
centimes de 1991 étaient tous du signe
du lion ou ascendant lion
paulette hamad à 15 millions de francs
mais le 4942 lyon
henry rivaux 13 millions de francs dès
le 24 juillet 1928 lyon hélène b 6 19
millions de francs dès le 15 août 1954
ascendant lion
jean par des 17 millions de francs dès
les 8 ou 10 940 lyon qui a changé c'est
surtout de ne plus être travaillé le
matin tôt rester chez soi d'être libres
libres de ne plus être pris par l'état
et argent en fin de compte un set chose
de merveilleux de fabuleux
mathématiquement une personne n'a qu'une
chance tous les six ans 73 ans de
couches et de gros lot alors coïncidence
ou réelle influence de l'astrologie sur
la loi des probabilités à la française
des jeux ne conteste pas le fait mais on
refuse de le commenter je ne suis pas du
tout surprise car justement en 91 ce
sont sans conteste les lions et les
ascendants lyon qui ont profité des
meilleures influent de chance puisque
jupiter trônait dans ce signe jupiter
jeu le grand bénéfique c'est la planète
de la chance par excellence il favorise
la réussite légal expansion et
éventuellement une plus grande richesse
et en 93 ce sont davantage les
capricornes qui vont connaître un grand
bouleversement et qui ont donc aussi un
grand potentiel de chance également les
autres signes de terre comme les
taureaux et les vierges
en 1991 tous les gagnants milliardaire
du loto et est du signe du lion ou
ascendant lion alors coco est de l'intox
et ce de l'info je vous le demande et je
demande à karen cheryl candidat guy
juste l'inversé les choix a toujours un
sens des aiguilles d'une montre que je
me fasse une petite fille mais après tu
seras là ma chérie alors mais à ton avis
qui
m'a d'abord je vais doubler la question
par une autre question est ce
l'idée question je réponds
à
poser le problème oui j'ai entendu
parler que l'auto stop star est non
excusez-moi maître capello que
voulez-vous coussin midi j'ai entendu
parler que et vous dit rien vous non je
dirais plutôt j'ai entendu dire que bon
mais ce n'est qu'un péché véniel hockey
d'absoudre ok d'accord alors je
m'entends dire
j'ai entendu dire que le savoir une fois
par an deux fois par an et deux tranches
du loto en faveur des gosses quand pat
vacances dont je m'occupe et qui se fait
des malheureux j'ai entendu parler que
les courses et ça je pousse à la roue
qui est de temps en temps des courses
entièrement destiné aux enfants aussi
pour qu'ils croquent à leur fin et
qu'ils aillent en vacances j'ai entendu
parlé de beaucoup de choses est-ce que
ce quai de la fosse d'intox sa toque et
payer des vacances de ce boîtier
est ce que c'est de la fraude la toque
c'est un fou ce que tu veux dire hélas
non c'est de l'intox parce que c'est ni
lait ni le taux ni les courses nouvelle
se décider à faire ça pour le risque de
voir ces camps pour alors puisque tu as
voulu déplacer par
karen les gagnants milliardaire du loto
en 1980 ils étaient au nombre de combien
joue pas ici soussac nous était lions hu
à 100 dans lyon 6 ou 7 tu veux que je
fasse un pourcentage avec ça écoute je
vais dire je dire pourquoi pas je veux
dire un fond ça sera un pur hasard info
toi tu as byatt j'y tiens tu as juste
rajouter un truc je trouve ça très très
très très con non non tout ce qui
étonnant tout ce qui est loto de ce qui
t'a quotas tout ce qui m'énerve qu'ils
machin j'ai quand même un vieux prétexte
pour prendre du pognon parce que ceux
qui jouissent ceux qui n'ont pas
d'accord qu'on leur prend du pognon le
redonne à un mec qui gagne l'état prend
énormément au passage et je trouve que
mon fils déjà beaucoup à l'état
oui
les mots d'en donner vos la course sur
les mots ça sera un alibi alors moi je
pense que c'est pas possible que ce soit
toujours les mêmes qui est d'une même
d'un même signe qu'ils aient gagné et
j'étais combien six ou sept à six ou
sept fois bon alors c'est une question
qui a été envoyé par monsieur christian
raked 92 bois colombes qui gagne déjà
2000 balle il a tourné son sujet les
bravos
maintenant pour savoir si je rajoute
mille francs 2 ma poche et oui laisse
les cieux mais non non non non ces deux
maps abbaoui et le cheval gagnant par à
témoin de cheval gagnant très gentil
alors on prend ce petit téléviseur et on
regarde la réponse c'était de l'intox
évidemment tous les gros gagnants
n'étaient pas des cibles et ils y ont
d'ailleurs je suis une des premières
victimes quand mon mari et lyon et même
à 120 lyon et il a joué jouer en 91 et
il n'a pas été parmi les millionnaires
et on doit continuer donc alimenter la
tirelire à la mise
[Applaudissements]
alors corti et maître capello quel est
le score thierry est ce que tu peux
répéter en question c'est le truc je
comprends pas avec m
alors il pourrait être prendre ton ut le
poète france on lutte et dix meilleurs
que karen et nagui fait notre
incomparable guy que nous applaudissons
[Musique]
j'ai pas tout compris mais je traduit
simultanément pour les gens qui n'ont
pas compris donc zéro car n 1 à 10 et 2
guy lux bras
allez
avant l'interview karen cheryl je
voudrais reparlait de l'amour écorché de
bernard huvelin chez grasset beaucoup de
temps avec eux quand c'est non c'est un
lycée en a tiré un livre quand même bien
beaucoup de téléspectateurs s'étonne
qu'il n'ait pas eu de prix à la rentrée
et pour nous cela en dit long sur les
pratiques éditoriales
beaucoup de téléspectateurs s'étonne
aussi que ce livre ne soit plus
trouvable dans les librairies eh bien il
faut continuer à le demander merci
d'avoir suivi nos conseils bernard
huvelin l'amour écorché chez grasset
ça va lui a valu sa vie tu as lu la
nourriture chez non non je ne savais
même pas que c'était chez grasset chez
grasset voilà très bon bucarest et à
besson qui a pas eu besson en plus à
réparer oui
côte à l'os occupé de claude la caisse
du thé acheter
le gars fatah reste je t'ai dit le sous
estimer que la bière dessus est
allé l'argent dit il doit certainement
être un puissant
de bons souvenirs dont tu étais très
inspiré la gt pas vraiment inspiré
j'étais plus district maintenant
sûrement oui alors il paraît que tu es
devenu tout doux gentil gentil je suis
devenu hyper gentil on à dire tu donnes
l'exercice de style doit montrer de quoi
tu es capable mais nous n'avons pas du
tout regarde maintenant bon déjà je suis
à 10h30 bref de faire 1 8h30 quand je
suis devenu très doux bâle a par exemple
pour faire un litre et demi par ton
animateurs ont six points comme en
passant mon interview quelqu'un a une
chanson en promotion en ce moment chez
polydor une très bonne maison excellent
excellente et s'appelle comment ta
chanson elle enverra l'on verra pas de
commençons alors à l'envers à l'endroit
à l'endroit on comprend mal envers
pourquoi ça veut dire quoi
l'on rencontre à la télévision ont
toujours été un petit peu houleuse
j'espère que celle de ce soir démentir à
ce qui a pu se passer dès les années
précédentes a décidé de vous faire des
routes pas de t'offrir des roses mais de
te féliciter pour le jeu que tu animes
tous les soirs sur france 3 de 20 heures
à 20 heures 15 ce qui s'appelle hugo
délire
partout sur la france aujourd'hui des
orages des bourrasques des pluies
glacées enfin bref le long cauchemar de
l'hiver avoué qu on est quand même
beaucoup mieux chez soi devant son petit
écran a joué avec go non si vous avez
raison et en plus on a un top3
absolument exceptionnel explique tout ce
jeu comment ça se passe comment ça se
passe ce qui est amusant c'est que les
gens peut jouer deux chez eux donc
simplement avec un téléphone tout à fait
traditionnel téléphone à touches et
il appelle un standard qui s'opposent à
ce standard pendant direct de l'émission
ils vont être aux commandes en fait des
images gérer les images à l'écran en
direct simplement pianotant sur le
clavier téléphonique et en faisant se
déplacer un petit personnage sur les
grands projets riches et puis qu'on a
des jantes sur un clavier c'est ça voilà
un et ça marche bien et ça marche très
très bien on a un minimum de 25 mille
appels par jour avec parfois des pointes
à 40 milles et puis surtout on a plus
que doublé l'audience depuis le début de
l'émission et puis rajouter donc
d'autres émissions puisque au départ
c'était prévu du lundi au vendredi
maintenant c'est du lundi au samedi avec
des petites réapparition un peu plus
tard c'est arrivé à lui c'est là un
c'est pas une idée à moi on me l'avait
proposé quatre ans j'ai très bête et
chez moi je n'ai pas accepté et tu vois
et ça ne pas l'avoir sur les chemins du
temps de parce que ça marche oui mais
j'aime pas venir je n'aime pas par des
trucs aux danois s'est classé devenir
way j'étais sûr de faire jouer des gens
alors parc en direct c'est une question
qui me brûlait l'asie fait l'interview
week end qu'est ce que fait ce que font
les 25 personne en dehors des deux qui
joue ou celui qui joue les 25000 autres
ils font quoi d'abord elle espère
pouvoir jouer éventuellement lendemain
et puis surtout ce qui est marrant c'est
devant le but le parcours donc en direct
à l'écran et voir comment se comportent
celui qui est devant son téléphone et le
bts dans l'eau sur le jeu non ça s'en
occuper
dis-moi karen tu vas rencontrer combien
de fois l'homme de ta vie pas encore six
mois je n'ai jamais compté six mois
c'est tout moi j'étais 7e petit naturel
si sam de ta vie jusque c'est pas
méchant je peux tout dire ça quand même
bien sûr santé n'était pas je ne
désespère pas clos et l'amour absolu tu
veux faire écouter ses parents il va
falloir allonger les missions au claude
eric rodrigues thierry pierre et jean
touya faisait
bien sûr là ce soir pourtant
on les a retrouvés mais pourquoi tu as
eu autant de ta vie pourquoi ça va
jamais qu'est ce qui se passe mais
écoute d'abord homme de ma vie ça c'est
les gros titres de la presse populaire
noix ou presse dite à scandale non c'est
simplement que je suis une éternelle
fiancée bien comme ça voilà une femme
libre indépendant à partir de maintenant
il y en a pas eu tant bart et oui tout à
fait pas aigri sans nostalgie
voilà et tu es toujours avec ton
mexicain la tombe au branle à l'homme
d'affaires que tu vas voir de temps en
août il va falloir vraiment que je
demande aux mecs d'ailleurs ce sont
toujours des pseudonymes le type qui
donc a signé cette interview d'enfance
dimanche va vraiment falloir que on
organise une entrevue pour je me pose
des questions parce que ces accès
extraordinaire compte hier ce type donc
d'interviews qui qui paraît tu n'a bien
évidemment pas rencontré de journalistes
mais le mexique assez fréquent puisque
10 interwiew qui paraissent tu
rencontres à peu près deux ou trois fois
un journaliste mais ça les lecteurs
l'ignorent cette histoire de mexicains
c'est vrai c'est pas vrai qu'ils
manquent d'imagination et coutumes
ennuis et y vas tu vas pas mais coûte
mais tu as vraiment pas changé un un peu
quand même
casse toi pourquoi parce que j'ai pas
envie de te réponds tu t'en fous c'est
paru dans le journal
italien écouter ce que je viens de te
dire
enfin il est bien un truc vrai au départ
jeudi à ils vont pas parler d'un
mexicain si c'est pas vrai on pourrait
pas voir un vrai animateur
tu veux que je me casse vraiment way
[Applaudissements]
ouais
ouais j'étais en plein coeur du bien de
sortir d'ailleurs où je mets les toits
un petit peu assez bon quand on l a
finalement préféré samedi à tanger le
look ardisson donc je vous dit voilà je
suis désolé mais pour guy lux que je
respecte énormément jeunes clergyman de
froch et voilà alors c'est comme ça bon
le mexicain alors par devant par
derrière ouais
on va continuer
à temps il ya un truc c'est que je suis
quand même bien donc j'aimerais bien
rester
donc j'ai commencé par prendre des
mesures pour rester je vais virer baffie
je suis obligé ma fille non je suis
désolé été ouverte en au placard et où
j'ai peur doit libérer de france 2 des
jeux qu'à ce
moment
[Applaudissements]
alors il n'y a plus qu'à faire une auto
interview en fait daniela lumbroso
depuis quelques temps vous voit plus à
la télévision pourquoi je me retourne
excusez moi
et bien il se trouve que je ne suis plus
à l'antenne vous avez remarqué ça me
fait très plaisir bon voilà quoi c'était
bien fait rire
[Musique]
désolé qu'on ne voit plus
je suis sûr que bientôt après une petite
caste pour beaucoup et il fait très beau
monde j'espère qu'il va revenir mais oui
père et fille car on attaque une
question d abel piot 75 paris attention
les propriétaires de perruches
risque deux fois plus qu'il ya un corps
non les poupées russes risque deux fois
plus ainsi à cancer du poumon dit
propriétaire entend les bons jeux c'est
d'une manière générale que de la voir
des oiseaux chez soi c'est pas très sain
dont on a vu des poules tout
moment tu crois pas toi ouais j'ai du
mal à le croire quand même temps la
perruche donc intox intox
moi j'en ai fumé eu un jour c'est vrai
que ça la
carène j'ai envie de dire info info eh
bien c'était de l'info on a pleuré
les clips
les plus ils sont porteuses de tumeurs
il ne faut jamais lâcher un oiseau raya
marine hécatombe de vol
alors qu'isabelle piot 75 paris gagne
donc 500 francs et on l'applaudît
maître capello score
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi capello toujours capello à
l'oscar moi je vous le dit parker guy
lux 2 nagui de karen
à l'eau il m'avait cru mort et fut dupe
on peut parler de ta carrière si cet
amuse prenez votre petit téléviseur à
regarder car elle chantait et ensuite on
va parler de la carrière de carey sage
attendait
[Musique]
le temps
[Musique]
il est pas
arrêtez pas quand avait été le premier
prix de batteries conservatoire kenny
clarke de chanter des chansons comme ça
l'union et d'écouté chez toi herbie
hancock chick corea miles davis john
coltrane et coûte effectivement c'était
pas les chansons intello tout ce que
j'ai fait je leur dis pas je les fais
avec une espèce comme ça d'énergie et de
bonne humeur c'est vrai que maintenant
ça appartient au passé et puis ça a été
un parcours amusant intense c'est vrai
qu'il ya 15 millions de disques vendus
en dix sept ans et puis voilà j'ai pris
ce virage peut-être que j'ai
suffisamment égratigné de tympans et
voilà moi j'aimais bien aussi ouais
qu'est ce que tu penses que tu es tu as
des amis dans le métier dans la dans la
chanson des filles écoutent curieusement
mes amis en fait tout faux pas vraiment
partie de ce métier je n'ai pas assez de
voix jeanne mas va c'est moi qui te
casse
on va terminer sur une bande d'acteurs
du coq à l'âne fait prête pas d'accord
est-ce que tu préfèrerais être un coq ou
annan
lui préférant celle là
avec les invités je préfère être une
petite poulette et qu'une tirés avec le
coq l'insultent qui t'a fait le plus mal
l'un sulky par exemple pourrait me faire
le plus mal des compliments venant de
toi ouais donc aujourd'hui terrain
d'attendre voilà non les compliments
quand ils sont pas sincères c'est comme
une insulte à l'intégrité 10 mois est ce
que tu as déjà pensé au suicide
au tiers du roman
espérant provoquer
c'est bien sûr par amour mais là j'ai
envie de jouer envie de répondre un peu
plus gravement d'extrapoler en fait
tiens j'ai envie de te dire que quand tu
es amoureux tu construis des châteaux en
espagne il m'a juste mon amour amor en
espagnol ça se dit la même façon [__]
toile n'est ce pas ma fille
ça peut entraîner des cons parce que
tout ce qui est maintenant ça prend très
bien comment pourquoi s'est-elle ici à
tulle attire bernard barsi n'ont jamais
quand même
qu'est ce que tu as des plus sexy
antoine mangin poc y paraît oui il
parait ma bouche c'est vrai et de moins
c'est que c'est d'être sexy en fait
c'est s'est dégagé comme c'est une
espèce d'électricité de magnétisme être
sceptique aux autres et quand soudain tu
deviens plus que cérébral et non mes
états d'âme voilà qu'est ce que tu es
l'entente demandent des autographes
écoute alors là vraiment ça dépend de la
personne du contexte et puis de mon
humeur je m'adapte est-ce que tu m'aimes
oui
moi non plus d'accord est-ce qu'il faut
coucher pour réussir maintenant la
preuve puisque je suis là on peut faire
ça deux bouts signaux l'époque
où voudrais tu te marier ou je voudrais
me marier il faudrait d'abord que tu me
poses la question voudrais tu te marier
je suis sûr qu'il va vouloir se marier à
un moment où je voudrais me marier way
en provence ah bon palin maurice n'ont
pas bon tu vas reprendre ton petit
téléviseur et regarde
l'île maurice petit île perdue dans
l'océan indien est connu dans le monde
entier pour son climat tropical sa
douceur de vivre la beauté de ses plages
et ses superbes fonds sous marins afin
d'apporter à leur séjour un souvenir
impérissable
les touristes étrangers peuvent s'y
marier
et depuis quelques mois un hôtel de la
côte ouest propose dans son catalogue
l'organisation d'une nouvelle formule de
mariage le mariage sous marin prestation
incluant une formation à la plongée sous
marine
notre clientèle qui vient
essentiellement d'europe via maurice
pour des vacances exotiques et on
propose des mariages ici la pirogue des
mariages traditionnels on s'est dit que
pourquoi pas en dehors du cadre normal
des mariages ont pour offrir quelque
chose pour les adeptes de la plongée
sous-marine et offrir une partie la
cérémonie soulom parmi les poissons
comme témoin
évidemment c'est beaucoup plus simple
d'avoir un mariage traditionnel dans le
jardin ou même sur la plage mais ce côté
sous-marin ajoute une note
tout à fait créative et inoubliable mais
cette note sous marine inoubliable
n'est-elle pas incompatible avec la
législation mauricienne concernant les
lois du mariage pas du tout dans le sens
que une fois que le papier a été signée
le lieu où la loi ne change en rien
l'arc de mariage quoi que ce soit sous
l'eau ou faire une montagne ça change
pas la loi en m c'est vers un fonds de
15 mètres dans une eau à 25° que les
jeunes mariés descendent accompagnés de
leurs témoins
un terroriste poisson tropical gardien
des lieux est là pour les accueillir la
cérémonie finale du mariage peut enfin
commencer luttant contre le courant au
milieu de la haie d'honneur formée par
les témoins les jeunes mariés sacrifier
au rituel du passage des anneaux et du
baiser
[Musique]
non
je
[Musique]
cette formule a déjà rencontré beaucoup
de succès auprès des touristes elle
reste néanmoins dangereuse il y a trois
mois une cérémonie a été interrompue par
l'arrivée inopinée d'un couple de
requins
[Musique]
à l'île maurice à l'hôtel organise des
mariages sous marins info ou intox guy
lux
il se passe tellement de choses sur la
mer émergent porte pas de savoir si on
fait gaffe à ce que
je pense que c'est vrai là je pense que
c'est vrai nagui moi je suis médusé un
peu mais
entre phoque ouais tu as dit autre chose
pour la projection du sujet ils causent
pas le répéter que quoi comme ça on est
sûr que la mariée mouiller
c'est ainsi c'est tout le monde crie au
génie je peux appliquer appliquer des
plans mais moi je deviens fou ouais
l'info et toi faut aussi un faux aussi
alors c'est un sujet qui nous a été
envoyé par monsieur pierre à noël 75
paris sujet salée ouais c'est un sujet
ça les non dits non
chômage ma fille qui gagne deux mille
fois puisqu'on a tourné son sujet
maintenant pour savoir si je rajoute
mille francs de ma poche et oui on
écoute la réponse est bien c'est de
l'intox parce que il faut savoir qu'il
n'ya aucune agence de voyage qui
proposent de mariage sous marin lui
maurice nous trouver ça dans aucun
catalogue mais il faut savoir que c'est
quand même une expérience extraordinaire
parce que se remarier au bout d'un
embrayage puisque nous allons fêter noël
dans le mariage
saint-gilbert en plongée c'est quand
même quelque chose de formidable
jamais vu quoi j'ai une connerie parce
que j'ai un mauvais perdant la ville est
pas content non toi toi qu'est-ce que tu
avais dit je suis ça scandaleux parce
que l'information
j'avais dit j'avais dit je vis un faux
ouais donc je me plante non mais
maintenant c'est là qu'est ce que tu
avais mes petits camarades pareil on
sait tous plantés vous êtes tous plantés
planter un strike c'est génial c'est un
strike orties le score
écouter parler philippe qui jamais le
fils ali ben ben
rien n'a changé
ne soit rien n'a changé guy lux 2 1 à
10,2 et karen à quoi
jacques martin l'a dit à mes côtés
comment veux tu ne pas avoir la grosse
tête après des trucs pareils mauvais
choix la place de ce garçon oui oui
pourquoi ans et applaudi alors qu'on
s'est gouré tous les trois c'est qu'on
truc là c'est très con je savais très
bien que cette explication à [__]
[Musique]
bonjour on passe pour les étrennes la
mesure à besoin d'un relevé d'identité
bancaire s'il vous plaît
parce que là on change la formule on va
prélever directement sur votre compte et
les étrennes la de fin d'année pour noël
donc il faut simplement un rib on vous
voulez donner plutôt ça soit franc ils
sont 3000 francs par mois d'aidé traîne
là
donc on chante la formule madame en
demande aux fai mais attendez vous
raconter mille francs par mois donc vous
refusez de données pour pour le central
la voilà que j'avais le droit madame
vous avez le droit de refuser
ma cheville et des lettres recommandées
donc on va plus de lettres recommandées
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
j'ai donné comme tous les ans
vient d'apporter ce
que je sais c'est pas moi vont disputer
- madame moi j'applique les consignes
j'ai des consignes on n'a pas de moyens
de pression sur les gens pour avoir des
étrennes
d'accord ok alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire non mais
refus attendait m'engueuler pas moi je
suis pour rien monsieur rigal aller à
les convaincre qu'on écrive une note et
si vous refusez vous n'aurez plus d'être
commandés nord est et apostate facture
m'écrivent comme l'attestent la
déchetterie les régions jamais
pour me plaindre concédé mais ça vient
de lui c'est lui qui ait envoyé
circulaire là je lui dirai voilà me
direz je publierai ça dans les journaux
bien sûr
je vais vous receviez des lettres
recommandées monsieur parfois vont vous
receviez presque j'avais donc là
maintenant c'est plutôt jamais un des
mandats également non plus les cartes
postales rarement bella sera plus du
tout des factures d'edf ok on les
supprime également un parce qu'on va
plus les distribuer le monsieur parce
que comment voulez vous on a pas moyen
de pression
c'est pour les étrennes vous donner en
fonction du service
bon ben nous aussi on distribue en
fonction du don donc si vous donnez pas
eh ben on va mal distribuer le courrier
bah oui c'est dégueulasse mais ils le
font tous
attendent et le receveur monsieur les
complices puisque c'est pour picoler à
la poste
c'est normal la
chanteuse
gênes a carrément taux
assez
bas de wii noire est
vite alors tout le butin sans moi c'est
sympa attention chacun ouais bon
ok j'arrête
et il n'y a pas de raison qu'ils avaient
prévu je suis désolé les gars mais je
m'éclipse et
ben non pourquoi donc de bonnes pourquoi
nancy privé c'est privé mais par exemple
on peut demander à ma copine daniela de
venir le remplacer elle va faire ça la
cave a très très bien
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue à bord
bonjour il n'y a pas de raison je suis
content
très content parce que j'ai trouvé du
boulot finalement dernière savais plus
quoi faire de toi sur cette chaîne
quoique qu'est ce qui se passe ça sympa
le cadeau
pour les bretons amusez vous mais moi de
mon côté j'ai un petit peu travaillé
pour vous depuis tout à l'heure
maintenant que je suis bien installé
c'est tout de même plus facile alors je
voudrais vous dire simplement au lieu de
perdre votre temps avec un sujet comme
les jeux télé qui manifestement
n'intéresse personne je voudrais vous
proposer un certain nombre de vrais
sujets des vrais sujets pas de cette
espèce de gaudriole gratuites dont vous
vous gargariser de semaine en semaine
des vrais sujets par exemple le métier
d'éclusier n'est ce pas que tu un métier
en voie de disparition eh ben c'est
passionnant sa sas à savoir portage
c'est formidable ou bien le
désenclavement des zones de montagne et
la région du puech par exemple dans les
hautes-alpes c'est une région magnifique
comment la désenclaver voilà un beau
sujet ou bien leur même puisque on
approche des fêtes de noël comment
fabrique-t-on le foie gras en périgord
besoin le gavage des oies la truffe 1 il
faudrait faire parler des paysans qui
maintiennent cette tradition là bas dans
cette région de france que tout le monde
aime tellement voilà une belle émission
de noël plutôt que la vie sexuelle de
nagui ou je ne sais quoi alors continuer
je vais vous trouvez d'autres d'autres
choses les images du cochon ouais bon à
la vie de trois soeurs
6 et hallebardiers partir les bars dils
arribart dit tu as l'habitude de toucher
ou noir 1 km
de chez noir que d'une manière
officielle
maggie bonsoir vont sortir y entrer par
an et merci donc je remercie ma fille
pourrait 1 c'est très sympa franchement
je suis enseignant fait ses classes à
ses patrouilleurs du type c'est la
première dix mois dit me levy cette même
si tu veux quoi non voyants veux dire
c'est que l'intérieur est beaucoup mieux
que là on dit on dit que c'est plein de
vie de nagui bonsoir dans tes parents
étaient enseignants oui tous les
premiers alexandrie ouais ta maman était
française non papa égyptien oui non la
cua
l'audience tu veux dire oui
attends attends attends tu rigoles
atalante a le double elle double la
question
est ce encore les bio chez nous a permis
de séjour est ce qu'avoir est une star
de la télé tu as souffert le thé origine
on y arrive on est vraiment franchement
jamais jamais jamais ce qu'il faut dire
c'est quand tu dis prof père égyptien
mon prof mon prof mon père était
professeur de littérature française à la
sorbonne et ma mère prof de français
latin grec tu vas donc j'ai jamais été
vraiment éduquer ambiance zone
industrielle baston
m j'ai tiré j'ai tiré des bécanes j'ai
volé des trucs oui mais enfin bon ça
c'est normal vous et pour s'entraîner je
sors de ton portefeuille tout à l'heure
j'ai trouvé des trucs j'ai trouvé des
trucs dans la top top donc dis moi
adolescent tué habitait à cannes c'est
facile là bas ça l'est parce que dans le
midi quand même ils sont durs les gens
non non non ça devrait aller ouais ouais
on bien ouais et qu'une fois une fois
j'étais agacé par un flic ça c'était un
truc vraiment bien à quoi non sorties
sorties de bahuts des cannes sans casse
bande de potes machin enfin tout ce
qu'on peut imaginer pas méchant et puis
il ya un flic qui nous arrête contrôle
de papiers il prend mon adresse si la
recopie sur un petit papier où ça et
puis minar en dix ans maintenant je sais
où tu habites sale [__] ah oui drogba
est drôle sympa sens de l'humour est
partie puisqu'il enseigne donc moi je me
roberge points à béganne avec le casque
et les potes et on va tous au
commissariat jean délation style voilà
ce qu'a dit elle mais qu'on a porté
plainte le gars était viré lourde et là
où j'ai dû alcoolo et tour il a fini au
front national ça
ban pour dire quand même à sa décharge
qui s'appelle maigret qu'il appelle des
projets
cette souvient du gala de la hes so foot
de cannes il ya des images pire que ça
ouais c'est quoi les premières émissions
de tmc ou par exemple il n'y avait
qu'une caméras ont filmé en fumée en
bêta et ils bêta donc c'est un mode
enfin une cassette et une caméra et ont
filmé quatre fois la même séquence donc
on disait quatre fois la même phrase
donc à près de 80 langues qu'on disait
quatre fois la même phrase donc on
disait quatre fois la même pas qu'on
dise et quatre fois la même phrase même
cinq fois pour le montage même cinq fois
pour le montage dis moi je suis et il
monte pour voir des en 10 mois tu as
après tu as trahi dans une radio pirate
à vintimille c'est ça ouais non ses
avants chronologique l'avancé en 79 80
la radio était au dessus de vintimille à
bolt gay et là on travaille pour 30
fondeur tu vas gens les ménages ouais
ensuite a fait 3 ans sur radio côte
d'azur radio france codesion d'être
alizés yahvé radio 7 à paris ils ont su
wei portait à croiser chantal lauby et
bruno carré qui ont été les premiers les
premiers à me donner envie de
de faire de la télé gère du maire plus
sérieuse en l'occurrence à fr3 il
connaissait du monde ils m'ont dit
représenter machin on était on est
toujours d'ailleurs très potes tous les
trois toujours très potes aussi avec
bull privé m6 les young gods est un way
ainsi boyer m6 après qu'ils apprennent
ont ils tous les machins normal durable
parce qu'il ya eu tf1 ça veut dire quoi
que j'en sais rien ça veut dire quoi
qu'on demandait que marie france brière
demandé sur l'a5 dominique cantien
demandé sur la une tu allé sur la lune
taffin émission qui s'appelait comment
le vendredi soir n'en savait pas comment
elle s'appelle et puis quoi encore voilà
sap et puis quoi encore la durée
durée 12 numéros ouais pas lourd elle a
duré douze numéros c'est vendredi soir à
minuit et on a été supprimée d'antenne
parce qu'on faisait beaucoup plus qu
arthur maintenant
qu'ancien l'a dit il ya 10 à 2 il ya
deux personnes que si les chiffres sont
là j'ai fait deux erreurs elle a dit
c'est eric galliano et et nagui mais
elle m'a dit qu'après elle avait dit non
non j'ai dit que c'était une erreur
d'horaires c'était trop tard c'était mal
placé tonnerre à la toile c'était quoi
dial et d'y avoir cru peut-être trop
vite ouais ouais j'ai cru que tout
allait toutes les heures du jour au
lendemain j'étais sur une
je rentrais sur la plus grande chaîne de
télé j'étais sûr je suis toujours sur
rtl mais enfin c'est la plus grande
radio enfin on te dit on arrête pas te
dire que tu es la plus grande chaîne la
plus grande radio donc tu vas devenir le
plus grand et ben on oublie c'est pas
grave après tes places et six mois à
perdre la grosse tête quoi attendre
quand tu appelles télé sur l'a5 et pour
faire un jeu alors je ne voulais pas le
faire voilà et alors si un truc que je
comprends pas dans toute l'histoire
c'est assez c'est clair mais comment tu
as pu faire un jeu sur le service public
qui était déjà c'est injuste sur une
chaîne commerciale faire personne n'a
dit que c'etait un c'est vrai que moi
j'étais tanné un tout petit peu là deux
pour qu'elle reprenne question que le
meilleur gagne non pas qu'ils sont en
train de changer que la meilleure gagne
parce que j'étais personnes qui avaient
un truc à faire avec cette émission là
ça moi je te soit autrement oui ça se
passe bien un way par rapport à des
chavannes l'attend mais où ce qui est
clair c'est que si on m'avait dit au
mois d'août quand on a pris l'antenne on
avait 12 % de parts de marché
pratiquement rien si on m'avait dit
qu'on en arriverait à dépasser des fois
la une je l'aurais pas cru ouais là
maintenant c'est bien mais ses gaffes et
ton succès je crois que c'est entente à
des contractions à la limite du
je-m'en-foutisme c'est à dire que comme
tu es pas vraiment envie de faire un jeu
comme tu as pris ça un peu deuxième
regret sûrement même si c'est génial
c'est après ça un peu au deuxième degré
tu as fait ça comme ça et finalement ça
marche très bien parce que les gens
jamais vu çà a animé un jeu comme ça ce
qui plaît j'ai besoin de plus et quand
je me fous du prof du jeu c'est vrai
maintenant les répondants on aime le
foot un peu tout ce qui se passe où es
tu en penses quoi toi abstenus c'est un
spécial a personnellement je suis en
admiration devant sa décontraction parce
que je lui avais dit et il se rappelle
je laissais jeudi c'était au temps de
procéder au parc des princes vaut pas
tripette lundi vaut pas tripette le jeu
et on a fait un jeu
haillan mais c'est lui c'est lui qui l'a
fait grincer pas de jeu et on a fait le
tour et plus tôt on ne peut pas tout dit
daniel d'avoir joué des téléspectateurs
qui n'ont rien raté parce qu'avant enfin
ceux qui arrivent juste maintenant il
faut qu'ils sachent que j'ai pas parlé
avant donc ils n'ont rien raté mais nos
vies
dont l'animateur de jeu bref bien ça
marche bien excellent dans ton domaine
comme qui dit que c'était mais encore
d'ailleurs c'est l'été quand il a
commencé je dois savoir si quand tu
auras son match j'aimerais comme guy lux
dégueulasse vichy
je veux dire jarry entendu le nancy de
traite de vieux os
si j'arrive déjà son âge
je serais déjà non mais sans blague et
pas dire encore si vous saviez de son
nom y a un truc il ya un truc qui me
fait plus qui fut relativement peur
c'est l'élevage et la mort et je sais
pas pourquoi je me vois moins
relativement vite et jeunes parents mais
bobby mais j'ai pas large comme ça
alors mais c'est peut-être pour ça j'ai
voulu mourir avant dix mois dans bien
des fois c'est quand même limite bord
cadre parce que bon le je m'en foutisme
j'ai assez bien regarde prends ton petit
téléviseur et regarde mais j'm'en
foutisme de monsieur nagui emmanuel
fouchet capoter
faites vous dans la vie bien sûr je suis
aux yeux dentiste pour l'épauler dans
dentiste pour les enfants
pour les drapeaux les dents pour les
dents de la bouche et dans de la bouche
d'alain d'or pour savoir je peux si bon
un petit bonjour rapide alors merci non
un petit bond à non non je vous en prie
non un petit palais et non à l'ue non on
n'a pas le temps si vous pourrez pas le
temps où on le sent bon le temps on a
laissé moi bah c'est pas possible pas
que les amoureux mais non seulement d'un
prix même si les wallabies en tant que
l'émission ou quoi
merci merci
les gens vous aviez drôle moi ces
[__] un choc mois et même baby est
choqué ça c'est plus beau compliment qui
puisse me faire long nagui on n'a pas ce
candidat-là en ligne on en a un autre
qui est qui est venu dans que le
meilleur gagne et qui voudrait te
raconter ce qui s'est passé après au
moins il a vécu le tournage wi lan puis
après quand il est retourné dans son
pays alors est ce que monsieur est ce
que est ce que vous êtes en ligne
alors comment s'est passé votre tournage
avec nagui et ensuite comment avez vous
été considérés quand vous êtes revenu
dans votre dans votre village dans la
france profonde on peut dire monsieur
oui bah justement moi j'ai le garagiste
de la mortagne pile de l'orne et j'ai
passé dans que comme candidats à
l'attribution est ce que j'ai trouvé
tout à fait du repas c'est que je dhabi
se moque de nous qu il utilise un peu
notre présence et notre timidité que
pour pour faire des jeunes on pourrait
voler
les assaillants ont marqué après les
gens se foutent de vous coacher veut ni
moins
mortagne du garagiste un client malgré
ça je trouve ça très très désobligeant
croissant pour les clients des soeurs en
plus ces garagistes quand même c'est des
voleurs
merci
si monsieur de votre votre témoignage et
comme vous le voyez ce garçon est
absolument pas prêt à ça près
alors du tout du tout mais s'il ya par
exemple le gars qui est passé et que
j'interromps involontairement évidemment
13 ça monte ça monte ça monte ce qu'il
faut vous dire quand même si à la fin de
la séquence il finit par passer son
message n'est pas redire son permis
parce que c'est ce qu'on dit vous allez
au début qu'on utilisait un jeu qu'on un
jeu intelligent ça dépend énormément du
son mais de ceux qui sont en face et à
bercy je suis ici on est soit de jouer
au tennis baker tu le mets seule femme
de coeur c'est un peu prétentieux même
tiens prenons un mec hyper forget tu
commences tu crois ouais ouais c'est
vrai le concours le comte je manage
aussi enfin vos boîtes étaient rarement
vulgaire toi je suis limite des fois que
ma part je suis limite limite tu as du
mal à dire des gros mots alors sois
gentil soit vulgaire pour une fois fais
nous plaisir
ta gueule grosses couilles tu veux
six mois c'est l'instinct non mais on va
faire une question avant apple sont à
voir s'impliquer autant le bariol 1
alors c'est une question de sylvie caron
75 paris le tien tu vas la tire toi
parce que comme c'est un truc bien
vulgos germa qui la posent cette
question
hollande les services de call girls pour
handicapés sont remboursés par la sécu
en sommes aux secure ouais tu regardes
pas la réponse aux attentes alors
monsieur guy lux pouvez-vous me répéter
ce que l'homme d'honneur il paye ses
[__] voilà servi
j'adore ya une baisse donc pas ce qu'est
ce qu'elle a les dents je te le dis en
confidence gratuite avec m
je suis dans une émission où il y à du
bonheur après m'étais bien simple c'est
bon alors est-ce de la foule c'est à
dire effectivement que j'
attends qui me dit ah tock ce matin j'ai
pas très bien compris daniela
à un faux lui a dit à toi tu dir weh
nagui moi je remette ça soit vrai ouais
serait génial tu imagines ouais bah oui
on se fait tous paralysés
j'aimerais bien jean lèques soif eh bien
c'était de l'info à
j'avais faire confiance aux émigrés
l'épaule alors tiens supporte jamais
croire en leur confiant un hollande
c'est considéré comme un acte médical la
seule condition mesdames messieurs c'est
de ne pas pouvoir se soulager soi même
alors souvent ne pas pouvoir
le pape polonais l'a7 bretois l'on sait
pour l'heure qu'à rennes c'est karen oui
non il était il est à sa caméra alors on
peut pas un nom vous rappelez merci non
non je suis un carême où ils l'appellent
rire vais
sylvie caron 75 paris gagne donc chats
sont francs et on l'applaudît
et maître capello le score et il fait
que je connais que
deux philippins d'avre d'eure jamais le
public n'en dors pas fini de parler
ses décors sont bons mais quand on mange
bien nagui à 3 way guy lux à 2 aïe aïe
aïe ah oui et puis la jeune qui vient
d'arriver dany lanaken ben c'est normal
c'est normal
à partir de janvier tu as une nouvelle
émission sur la chaîne france 2 c'est
quoi
ça devrait s'est pas encore bétonné
c'est à dire qu'on a un pas
finalisées fignoler toutes les missions
elle va parler français signalisés
maintenant
senio les ailes étanche et qui a pu
finaliser il est librement il a vomi
partout
mais il est au chaud maintenant alors
dans l'idée c'est de faire un mini
portrait un peu des risées pas se
prendre au sérieux gérant va essayer de
garder ce même ton justement et puis de
faire une émission de variétés comme je
fais une émission sur rtl où les gens
viennent jouer en direct chantent en
direct improvisent des duos font des
boeufs des trucs comme ça et chaque fois
depuis cinq ans n'arrêtent pas de me
dire tous les gens qui sont venus en
allant des frères jackson à offrir
jacques à karen qui n'est plus là où
ou encore jean jacques goldman haute
c'est pourquoi il n'ya pas ça à la télé
voilà donc on va le faire la télé puis
on verra bien en direct qu'en vrai
direct en vrai dire est que comme une
plaque de tout le monde sait exactement
tu sais là le jour de diffusion je sais
que c'est à 22h
est ce que c'est le samedi soir ça
dépend de toi vieux thann où tu te
calmes où tu te casses et pas le saunier
soit assurée
jay z une thèse admiratrice qui va te
poser une question c est à vous de
parler ma petite z
c'est cela oui c'est cela oui quelqu'un
à qui j'ai plein de questions table a
retrouvé de la voix qui est elle fixée
la date du feuilleton mais cela gay ou
alors c'est à deux pistons pour la télé
parce que pour passer à la tv c'est sûr
maintenant m'apprête à quitter
savoir si t'es un gros bazar
dernière cachia
quand tu peux me pistonner pour faire le
feu saqqaf alex il a dit qu'il faut
prendre la rubrique faits divers alors
été volés chez emmaüs avec les vêtements
pour noël comme ça je peux te répondre
alors toute l'affairé
je dis jamais que ça adhère il est fort
quand même pu tout à leur point de vue à
bord dont c'est que tout
cela va se calmer
c'est ce qui m'a qu'est-ce qui fait
mieux les filles que les hommes en forme
ouais
tu penses pas des affaires style bouton
ppda là tous ces journalistes à 49 des
billets d'avion et et tout ça oulala
d'abord suis je qualifie pour manger en
juge et puis
non sans jeter sans rien que je
t'interdis ouais ouais ouais je pense
qu'il ya c'est un métier où il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de magouilles
à tous les niveaux mais
ouais c'est facile de casser way
voilà non moi je trouve ça tout à fait
scandaleux moi parce que demain là je me
permets de le dire depuis la croquer toi
j'ai toujours j'ai toujours entendu
parler que tout le monde pouvait en
recevoir des des voyages des invitations
et tout ça ça existe dans tous les
métiers je vois vraiment pas pourquoi
tout d'un coup haro sur le baudet parce
que service saas et la télé
bon enfin bref imagine que tu sois sur
une chaîne privée bas et que tu es donc
le droit de faire la publicité pour des
produits et un jour coca cola te demande
de faire une campagne à guy je bois
coque et c est ce que tu accepterais où
tu refuserait non je ferai ce que je
bois énormément de coca cola tu le
ferais pepsi par contre je ferais tu
étais comme pétain finalement jeu comme
[__] tu apprends à pain dans la gueule
des regards
parce que les états unis tentent de
réduire nos exportations céréalières
subventionner les paysans en colère s'en
prennent aux produits le plus
emblématique de l'amérique le coca cola
depuis plus d'un siècle coca rayonne
dans le monde entier tout en se livrant
un combat acharné contre un autre géant
américain du soda pepsi cola
[Musique]
un duel savamment mises en scènes
auxquelles les stars du showbiz prennent
par elton john roule pour coca et
michael jackson préfère peps
[Musique]
mais au début du siècle la france avait
elle aussi un coca de renommée
internationale le coca mariani un
remontant bien de chez nous qui
utilisait le maréchal pétain pour sa
publicité
le quota mariani c'est ce qu'on appelait
à la fin du 19e siècle et jusque après
la première guerre mondiale un vin de
coca c'est à dire une boisson
reconstituante tonifiante contenant des
extraits de feuille de coca et le
maréchal pétain c'est prêter
effectivement à une publicité puisqu'il
a laissé publier son portrait avec une
dédicace de sa main où il dit que si les
français ont gagné la guerre de 14 c'est
grâce au coca mariage
c'est une invention
ne crois pas
gagné
c'est larry klein
c'est la réclame pour moi j'ai une
réclame qui a donc un arrière-goût de
publicité mensongère à moins bien sûr
que l'alcool contenu dans le cauca
mariani est donnée de l'ardeur au combat
à certains poilu de 14
- en vogue au début des années 30 le
coca mariani etondé lentement désuétude
c'est sans doute pour cela que philippe
pétain était moins combatif pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale l'autre vichy
n'est pas aussi tonifiante que le coca
mariani
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça a fait de la pub pour le coach
k alors est ce de la faute est-ce de la
taxe
commencer par moi même si ça comment
vois tu
m'écoutes avec marc ont défriché mais
lui il existe un jeu qui n'a pas inventé
eagle ben non c'est pas gueuler mais
c'est difficile de répondre toujours en
premier alors cela nécessite réflexion
justement rien
sais pas qui a des infos pour toute info
daniela
info info intox intox
c'était un sujet qui nous a été envoyé
par monsieur maurice hung 59
pont-à-marcq alors je vais te dire ce
moore il sung il en envoie lui des
sujets toutes les semaines à venir mais
ça je tiens à vous remercier femme
ginette ou get away est le pompe sont
d'ailleurs pour qu'ils envoient des blés
lui alors il a déjà gagné deux mille
francs puisqu'on a tourné son sujet pour
savoir si je rajoute mille francs de ma
poche pour m aider un petit peu
d'ailleurs sur ce coup on écoute la
réponse ce document date de 1925 à cette
époque le maréchal pétain le vainqueur
de verdun est un héros national et c'est
à ce titre qu'il a été sollicité par
angelo mariani pour figurer dans ses
albums publicitaires enfin ajoutons tout
de même que à cette époque là le fait
était parfaitement admis et qu'avant
pétain beaucoup d'autres célébrités
s'étaient prêtés à ce petit jeu mondains
comme par exemple edmond rostand rodin
mêmes et même le pape léon xiii
[Applaudissements]
alors maître capello et corti le score
si vous allez à la sortie du virage à la
cote je vois le vieux cheval qui lui ce
qui vient absolument attaquer le favori
de cette course qui était nagui le
protégé de la gac ans alors pour daniela
dans un fabuleux coup de rennes vient
égaliser les coiffer précisions quant
aux photos aux tirs au but 3 partout
certaines mercedes sont équipées de
trousse de secours avec une craie
blanche qui permet en cas d'accident de
tracer le contour de la victime en
quelle erreur info intox intox
j'ai une mercedes j'ai jamais vu daniela
j'ai vu l'addition mais pas la craie
aller quand il faisait partager jeudi
info nagui web et le maire fou et ben
oui je suis désolé ça va se terminer
entre deux trains c'était de la fausse
mort à tous les deux matins j'ai dit
exactement ça aussi pourquoi on y est
bon allez on y va en tant qu on
commencera par toi
des codes-barres sur les bombes
américaines correct pour aider
l'intendance à gérer son stock info ou
intox
info noyen troupes c'était de l'intox
vous avez perdu tous les deux
[Applaudissements]
et moi je vais élever les réclamations
près de mercedes j'ai une mercedes qui
m'a été livrés sans crainte ah bon je
vivais la tête mercedes
car il est mauvais joueur c'est
incroyable c'est encore peur n'aie pas
peur bien ça mais quand même laisser
patauger lui il m'a dit mon année une
mercedes centre est j'ai payé le prix
fort alors attention les enfants des
diplômes à puce pour faire face aux
contrefaçons info ou intox
ça peut être un projet je pense pas que
ça existe encore donc je tiens tox je
deviens fou alors c'est elle qui a gagné
bravo
c'est de l'intox
donc gagner là je vais pas toujours se
méfier des remplaçantes qui ont convergé
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
c'était déjà confessé guy bah oui comme
tout comme tout bon chrétien un mot
georges danton je ne lâche pas vraiment
parce que tu as été baptisé à 17 ans
quand ton frère s'est marié on l'aimé
gîte est croyant avant le baptême n'est
qu'une transition c'est un axe écrit
mais ça veut rien dire
et aujourd'hui tu as été en fait nous
aurons probablement je crois quand même
il ya des choses supérieur qui nous
régissent forces du bien et du mal un
jour je te vois un jour je te vois pas
je crois que la véritable dieu c'est
notre conscience que tu crois pas la
résurrection par exemple je crois pas à
la conception du saint-esprit non c'est
déjà du mal là j'ai du mal à franchir ce
pas c'est un peu ton facile de croire
que mais cela dit
le message laissé par le christ est une
un message de qui mérite quand même
d'être
suivi approfondi respecté
et on peut pas le nier quoi mais c'est
un peu niaise dix mois maintenant que tu
veux confessionnelle avec moi oui mon
père quelle est la plus grosse connerie
j'ai fait dans ta vie le jour où j'ai
été
m'installer dans la campagne de giscard
d'estaing
qui se passait du côté de la porte de la
villette dans les rôles dans le hall des
abattoirs est oui avait moi j'étais venu
comme ça ben c'est un petit mais pas
particulièrement
d'idées par l'amour que je pouvais
porter à giscard d'estaing et le hasard
a fait que quand ils m'ont vu arriver et
moi immédiatement dirigé vers l'estrade
la plus importante seul hic ans où il y
avait les invités de marque et au
précisément à la place que l'équité
alain delon pour faire son discours je
me suis retrouvé là bombardé par tout le
monde j'étais vieux trois jours après
vous avez été viré au moment où tu as
été viré par à partir des groupes tu as
vraiment pensé à se suicider à ce moment
là j'ai pas été heureux non je peux être
heureux surtout de la part de des
groupes dont il était certain que
j'avais été un de ses acolytes en 68
quand on voulait tous refaire la france
et comme j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer
mitterrand quelques années plus tard
quand il mène deux ans plus tard
impressionnant pinceau maintenant et
demi plus tôt même métier ramadi mais
vous savez mon chéri alex vous êtes un
professionnel de la politique ne compte
pas dans notre profond dans votre
profession par contre ceux qui courent
devant les roues et je voyais bien de
qui vous voulez parler et bien je
l'aurais jamais rien demandé et ils
courent devant les roues voilà ça
c'était ma consolation mais assez minime
par rapport aux halles un an et demi de
placard que j'avais connu 10 - la
connerie qui est amenée en taule même si
un an plus tard tu as été disons
éclaircies de tout soupçon là tu laves
est passé là bas se dire que si je
regrette de ne pas m'être rendu deux
autres fois de suite à la convocation du
juge d'instruction est d'ailleurs le
seul jour où j'ai quitté le palais de
justice j'ai dit à tous les journalistes
qui étaient là et d'ailleurs je lance
une petite pierre dans le jardin des
journalistes de tous les médias c'est
que pour ma sortie de taule comme pour
mon entrée judo en première page pour ma
relaxe et mon nom lieu j'ai eu droit la
14e page de trois lignes je te trouve
parfaitement incorrects et dégueulasse
de la part des journaux s'y
joue tu mourras ya ton fils à la roche
ça approche
je te trouve encore très enfants et on
fisc et là tu es une chose à lui dire tu
dis quoi et a fait le métier qui me
plaît c'est de bien le faire mais celui
là si tu devais prendre là le sillon que
j'ai tracé ce serait bien ce qui
malheureusement pas le cas pour
l'instant
[Musique]
oh
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus